den reality check mache ich mit nicole
boss sie ist europameisterin im
leichtgewicht und meine boxfilm expertin
als sportjournalist habe ich mich
mehrfach mit dem boxen befasst zuletzt
für eine geschichte über ihren wm kampf
in bern von da kennen wir uns
nicole boss ist 35 jährige box 2 20
jahren sie ist europameisterin im
wichtigsten boxverband des kontinents
akribisch bereitet sie sich diesen
frühling auf ihre karriere highlight vor
den wm kampf vor heim publikum
doch im ringen unterliegt sie der
weltbesten klar
der wm traum platzt
million dollar baby ist natürlich
immer mal wieder gesprochen
logan box firma aber er darf wirklich
nicht kritik sie als auch lea bis der
elz musste bissig wir schauen den film
merken er ist kitschig und realistisch
willi hob einst heimkind jetzt
weltklasse boxer
mit prächtigem zuhause kluger tochter
und schöner frau bis er alt das verliert
extrem viele klischees natürlich wollen
wir mit dem boxen bandic bringt laut
drogen waffen aber so hat er geschafft
im jahr nicht immer ganz so wie die
geschafft als eigentlicher auslöser
boxenhalt braucht
einen boxkampf gleich kämpft hob fortan
ums nackte überleben und im sorgerecht
für seine tochter
grandios gespielt von der elfjährigen
ohne lorenz die vater tochter beziehung
bestimmt die geschichte und sie bringt
hob zurück in den ring
jake gyllenhaal listen der rolle des
boxers unfassbar intensiv gerade im ring
vielleicht ist es das was die
faszination des films ausmacht wir sehen
nicht mehr den schauspieler sondern
einen getriebenen boxer
ich zeige die kombos wyhlen holt sich
auf die rolle vorbereitet hatte fünf
monate lang trainiert der zweimal
täglich jeden tag das resultat ist
sichtbar
vom morgen bis am aber fünf tage woche
oder sieben tage die woche 24 stunden am
tag wirklich anders macht
darstellen
ich hatte keine ahnung von boxen ich
wusste wenn ich es durchziehen will muss
ich es richtig lernen und wenn ich etwas
will dann richtung das macht mich stolz
und gleichzeitig hasse ich es an mir am
schluss spürte ich dass ich es schaffen
konnte
er schaffte es nicole boss und ich
werden uns in einem richtigen boxkampf
meine nächte disziplin echte agonie zu
erleben das ist eindrücklich
eindrücklich auch die box szenen werden
erinnert der ersten wochen gedreht ohne
jeglichen aufwand zu scheuen der ring
ist echt das publikum ist echt die
kameraleute sind vom amerikanischen
fernsehsender age biofilmen gewöhnlich
echte kämpfe und techno lässt sich im
ring nie doubeln
er ist wirklich sehr achtbar und abu
dhabi
und aber was auf
den wahlkampf
ein heroischer kampf zum finale hob
wechselt seine bestellung wird analog
zum filmtitel zum spa zum links schlagen
den rechtsausleger
south bronx sind außenseiter das passt
logisch
mit hirst mit der
tv
vermutlich
kaluga zu einem richtig offiziell rahner
mit popcorn mir bleibt spa ist eine
simple geschichte die durchaus real
wirkt ja mitten ins herz trifft das
boxer milieu liefert dazu den
kraftvollen gramm